kazim kazim kazim est un bon jour
françois n'ont rien aujourd'hui françois
merci bonjour je dis bonjour facteur
alors la tournée s'est bien passé oui je
me suis tellement dépêché que j'aimerais
moncheaux 1
vous voulez boire quelque chose ça ce
n'est pas d'europe lui 1 pour sûr je
boirai bien une petite limonade nani
manade vous n'avez pas vu casimir par
hasard non c'est bizarre d'ailleurs
voilà votre limonade
merci ô combien je vous dois rien du
tout facteur aujourd'hui c'est moi qui
vous la france est trop gentil vie mais
mais mais ce n'est pas comme ça que vous
allez faire des affaires vous me rendais
si souvent des services que les biens
naturels que je vous offre une petite
limonade
bah c'est bien gentil merci voilà alors
vous n'avez vraiment aucune idée de
l'endroit où peut se trouver casimir et
bien non vous savez à cette heure-ci
quand il n'est pas dans le jardin
personne ne sait ce qu'il peut faire
cette ennuyeuse vous avez quelque chose
d'important à lui dit pour sûr oui j'ai
une lettre en recommandé pour lui et
bien donné la loi mais voyons julie
c'est impossible
ah bon vous n'avez pas confiance en moi
me là n'est pas la question je voulais
vous avez peur que je la perde pas du
tout non 7
enfin je n'ai peur de rien je
l'imaginais pas le droit de vous la
remettre
mais comprenez - julie c'est une lettre
en recommandé
et quand une lettre est recommandé cela
signifie que le facteur s'engage à ne
remettre cette lettre aux destinataires
que contre la signature de celui ci bah
il nous prônons la signature de quasi
bien est le seul à pouvoir me la donnez
cette signature c'est casimir oublier me
voir acteurs oui en fait je suis bien
content de t'avoir g&g lettre
recommandée pour toi lettre recommandée
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien à
avait ça dépend ça dépend de ce qu'il y
a dans la lettre je peux être une chose
très intéressante et très bien et la
personne qui te l'envoie veut être sûr
que tu l'as recevra ou bien c'est une
choses désagréables est la personne qui
te l'envoie veut être sûr que tu auras
lu sa lettre est bien big moi d'abord si
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est pas possible il faut que si une
d'abord un nouveau nom
vous ouvrez et si tout va bien je signe
désolé casimir n'est un facteur n'a pas
le droit d'ouvrir les lettres mais si
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle enfin un peu
de courage d'aller kazemi signe signe
ici voilà bien et bien voilà talent est
allé mes amis et moi j'ai ma tournée
affiner un au revoir à bientôt un au
revoir on écoute julie j'aimerais que tu
ouvres problème parce que j'ai trop peur
donc d'accord il fallait pas t'inquiéter
c'est une lettre de l'oncle archibal mon
cher casimir c'est moi j'ai fait que tu
as un grand voyage au cours duquel je
dois passer près de l'île aux enfants
je ferai donc un détour pour venir te
voir demain
archibald fait un crabe au nouveau fonds
des sports tu vois il ne fallait pas
t'inquiéter année attend ya un post
scriptum j'ai hâte de voir ton jardin ça
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pourquoi c'est un petit jardin comme a
confié mon oncle archibald quand il a
quitté l'île aux enfants
ouais je ne m'en suis jamais s'occuper
va être dans une colère btp choix de la
rangée avant qu'il arrive un peu répond
je vais y aller il coûte non je me
laisserai plus tôt demain matin mais
casimir donc l'archipel a écrit cette
lettre hier
ouais et alors il s'est passé une nuit
entre hier et aujourd'hui
alors le demain de l'oncle archibal
c'est aujourd'hui demain c'est
aujourd'hui c'est trop compliqué et bien
pour être plus clair l'oncle archibal va
arriver d'un moment à l'autre
aujourd'hui oui oh mais c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle mais coûte à temps on
va appeler françois et les enfants ils
vont nous aider
françois les enfants vous venez que se
passe-t-il donc l'archipel arrive dans
les jardins de casimir d'un moment à
l'autre et je ne m'en suis jamais occupé
de ce jardin ne t'inquiète pas casimir
nous allons tous télé n'est ce pas les
enfants quasiment que des cités où les
outils pourquoi des outils mais il en
faut voyons nous même pour un petit
jardin mais évidemment ce casimir dont
on va aller ça les enfants vous allez
chacun chez vous et vous revenez le plus
vite possible avec des outils de
jardinage d'accord d'accord merci mes
amis et moi je vais préparer des
boissons pour tout le monde très bien et
ne t'inquiète pas que gémir tout va
s'arranger
[Rires]
bien c'est jacques qu'est ce que tu vas
au très bien on vient on a encore plein
d'autres la faire on l'a très bien
quelle collection ski en caroline à tous
les côtés qui arrive c'est formidable
les émirs moyens mais tu sais
franchement je crois que ces outils sont
trop grandes mais non casimir ne
t'inquiète pas et laisse nous faire bon
des enfants nous allons commencer par
expliquer à casimir comment s'appellent
ces outils et à quoi ils servent
d'accord celui ci empêche
c'est une belle et sincère et la terre
très bien ça retourner la terre on
dirait une grande cuillère
on voit ça va pas aller ce très joli
petit outil comment s'appelle-t-il une
quoi c'est pas loin cette fois ci fois
être très bien patrick c'est une serre
fait bon s'y reflète à deux parties
cette partie s'appelle comment cette
partie s'appelle la panne qui sert à
faire des trous dans la terre et ça
jack se sont dedans
à quoi sert la sphère fait ça foncer
pour retourner en terre faire des trous
ça sert aérer la terre quand on plante
des fleurs
moi j'ai pas besoin de s'être classé sa
vie cet outil c'est un râteau le gravier
la terre aussi quand on l'a bien
retourner avec la bêche pour légaliser
on se sert du râteau bon mais ça va pas
ça va pour le fixe à michael quel est
cet outil enfin c'est joli mais il est
beau s'appelle satané une binette
unacois si on devine est indispensable
très bien stéphanie ça sert à retirer
les mauvaises herbes dans les allées on
sait trop quand je comprends mais non
kenya s'est pas trop grand à l'ouvert
fois tu
c'est également une serre fouette un
petit peu différente de celle qu'on
avait tout à l'heure quelle est la
différence c'est ici
cette forte lorsque l'aiac dedans et il
ya une langue de plus ça d'un très bien
patrick ça s'appelle ça s'appelle une
langue
cette partie mais qu'est ce qui pousse
illégalement la panne à quoi sert la
langue patrick à quoi ça sert la langue
et se faire faire une petit sillon dans
la terre on a travaillé mon mac les
graines et faire pousser des fleurs
route très bien qu'à patrick qui lui
aussi est très utile bon comment
s'appelle ainsi d'une fourchette une
fourchette à casimir us alors comment
s'appelle-t-il c'est un ballet
métallique et sincère
ça va prendre et qu'on a laissé passer
la pause pour faire l'état des détails
on sait très bien que je trouve un canon
dans les allées quand les feuilles sont
tombées pour la casimir
mais françois tous ces outils sont trop
grands ne coûtent que j miro raid de
dire des bêtises tu n'y connais rien en
jardinage c'est vrai alors laisse nous
faire bon jeu les arrive avec plein de
boissons et de sandwiches pour vous
encourager au jardinage au minimum alors
casimir où se trouve-t-il qu'aujourd'hui
vous venez avec moi
allons-y les enfants écoutent casimir
l'est à malle magique nous n'avons que
très peu de temps mais we look
l'archipel arrive d'une minute à l'autre
mais mon jardin et là un jardin dans une
main mais oui je vous explique depuis
tout à l'heure que tous vos outils sont
trop gras mon jardin c'est un petit
jardin japonais comme ont donc posé sur
sa cheminée
j'ai juste à arranger impôts les
graviers
[Musique]